Organización meteorológica Mundial un
organismo científico de Naciones Unidas
advirtió Que las temperaturas globales
podrían cruzar en el próximo lustro el
umbral estableció en los acuerdos de
París de 2015
es prácticamente seguro que veremos el
año más cálido registrado Durante los
próximos cinco años una vez que termine
esta fase del niño
este pronóstico sucede cuando distintas
partes del mundo están sufriendo
inclemencias climáticas en Europa
Croacia e Italia padecen inundaciones y
registran muertos el cuerno de África ha
visto desbordantes crecidas de agua en
somalia y Etiopía mientras en Asia el
ciclón mocha continúa sacudiendo mi
hermanic bangladesh para la omm lo único
que se puede hacer es intentar que la
situación no empeore más
no hay vuelta atrás a los buenos viejos
tiempos porque ya tenemos una
concentración tan alta de dióxido de
carbono y también hemos aumentado la
concentración metano en la atmósfera y
lo mejor que podemos hacer es eliminar
gradualmente estas tendencias negativas
el aumento de la temperatura en parte se
debe al inicio del fenómeno del niño que
podría manifestarse en los próximos
meses en este patrón climático las aguas
son más cálidas en el Pacífico Tropical
calentando la atmósfera y elevando las
temperaturas globales